EMBARRASSMENT.
I WAS ABLE TO SPEAK TO THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER OF
UKRAINE TODAY AND WE SPOKE ABOUT
THIS SUBJECT.
HERE IS WHAT I LEARNED.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE A MASSIVE BLOW
TO RUSSIA'S WAR AGAINST UKRAINE.
UKRAINE'S FORCES SAYING THEY'VE
STRUCK THE FLAGSHIP OF PUTIN'S
BLACK SEA FLEET, THE GUIDED
MISSILE CRUISER.
I SPOKE EXCLUSIVELY WITH
UKRAINE'S NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER.
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE CRUISER?
IT SANK, HE SAYS JOKINGLY.
RUSSIA ADMITS THE SHIP HAS,
INDEED, SUNK BUT HAS NOT YET
ACKNOWLEDGED IT WAS STRUCK BY
KYIV.
INSTEAD, IT SAYS IT WAS BADLY
DAMAGED BY A FIRE, AND THEN SUNK
WHILE BEING TOWED IN STORMY
CITYINGS.
SEAS.
IT WAS INVOLVED IN A NOW-FAMOUS
INCIDENT IN A PLACE CALLED SNAKE
ISLAND, WHEN ITS CREW TOLD
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS TO SURRENDER.
THIS WAS THE ANSWER.
THE EVENT HAS BECOME SO
LEGENDARY IN UKRAINE, THEY HAVE
COMMEMORATED WITH IT WITH A
SPECIAL STAMP.
PEOPLE OF THIS POST OFFICE IN
KYIV STANDING IN LINE TO GET IT.
AN IMPORTANT EVENT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY.
OUR ARMED FORCES DESTROYED THE
AGGRESSORS' FLAGMAN SHIP.
I THINK THIS EVENT HAS TO HAVE A
PLACE IN EVERYONE'S MEMORY, THIS
MAN SAYS.
THE UKRAINIANS SAY THEY MANAGE
TODAY HIT THE SHIP, WHICH HAS
FORMIDABLE DEFENSE SYSTEMS WITH
UKRAINIAN NEPTUNE ANTI-SHIP
MISSILES.
IT WAS STILL THERE NEAR THE
SNAKE ISLAND, AND WAS HIT
YESTERDAY BY TWO POWERFUL
UKRAINIAN-MADE MISSILES, HE
SAYS.
AND THEN, A WARNING TO PUTIN.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING, HE
SAYS, THERE WILL BE MORE THAN
ONE.
BUT THE LEADERSHIP IN KYIV
UNDERSTANDS THE NEXT MAJOR
BATTLES WILL BE DIFFERENT, AND
POSSIBLY EVEN MORE BLOODY.
AS RUSSIAN TANKS AND ARTILLERY
POUR INTO THE DONBAS REGION.
THIS HOARD HAS INVADED OUR
COUNTRY, AND THINK WE WILL WATCH
THEM DESTROY US, HE SAYS.
BUT OF COURSE, WE WILL RESPOND
BY ALL MEANS WE HAVE THANKS TO
OUR INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS, WE
HAVE INTERESTING TOOLS.
THE U.S. AND ITS ALLIES HAVE
ALREADY PROVIDED UKRAINE WITH
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS' WORTH OF
WEAPONS, AND ARE NOW MOVING TO
GIVE KYIV HEAVIER ARMS TO
COUNTER VLADIMIR PUTIN'S TANK
BATTALIONS.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
SAYS UKRAINE NEEDS ALL THE
FIREPOWER IT CAN GET.
I WOULD NEVER SAY THE RUSSIAN
ARMY IS WEAK, HE SAYS, GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF WEAPONS THROWN THIS,
NUMBER OF TANKS, ARMORED
PERSONNEL CARRIER, PLANES, AND
HELICOPTERS.
I WOULD NOT SAY THIS IS A WEAK
ARMY.
I WOULD SAY THESE ARE STRONG
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS WHO FIGHT
BACK SUCH A POWERFUL ARMY.
AND THESE TERRITORIAL DEFENSE
SOLDIERS IN KYIV ARE VOWING TO
KEEP UP THE FIGHT.
THEIR ELITE TROOPS, GEARING UP
TO HEAD EAST.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY PREPARED FOR
THIS.
WE HAVE, BOTH, FIGHTING SPIRIT
AND FIGHTING MOOD.
WE ARE PATRIOTS OF OUR COUNTRY,
AND OF COURSE WE WILL FIGHT BACK
THE ENEMY, THE SOLDIER WHO GOES
BY THE N